[Musique]
agrippine s'éteint c'est un rôle
extraordinaire c'est un rôle du théâtre
classique évidemment xviie siècle il m'a
été proposé par eric ruf et stéphane
braunschweig tous les deux et je dois
dire que je je je ne voyais pas du tout
dans le personnage
je le connaissais pas en fait et le
personnage est extraordinaire j'ai
depuis découvert sa biographie et
d'autres choses
est ce que j'ai trouvé formidable succès
de femmes c'est que c'est une femme
d'une très grande intelligence
c'était un stratège politique c'est un
grand politique
c'était probablement la femme la plus
puissante de l'antiquité ce qu'on ne
sait pas suffisamment on pense toujours
que c'est cléopâtre ou bon pour défendre
un personnage moi j'ai besoin de les
aimer sinon ça ne passe pas donc
évidemment ça m'intéressait beaucoup et
puis le travail a commencé la pièce de
racine tels que stéphane braunschweig la
monte
c'est assez exceptionnel parce qu'il la
montre et la monte un peu comme la série
r house of cards dont il s'est inspiré
c'est à dire que c'est un lieu de
pouvoir contemporain ça pourrait être
l'elysée ça pourrait être la maison
blanche ou bien tout autre lieu de
pouvoir le bureau de donald trump par
exemple et nous sommes tous en
personnages avec des vêtements
contemporains et c'est une pièce sur
qu'est-ce qu'on va dire le pouvoir et
encore le pouvoir en fait vous savez
dans le france de 2018
les rôles de femmes sont très rares on
va pas dire que ça va jusqu'à 40 ans ça
irait peut-être
jusqu'à 50 oh mais en tout cas aussi les
mains après 50 ans on n'existe plus et à
la télévision presque plus non plus donc
heureusement le théâtre est là pour nous
défendre et je pense que c'est agrippine
il faut pas forcément la jouer à 90 ans
donc j'étais contente de la découvrir
avec mes 60 ans et j'espère la jouer je
ne sais pas combien de temps je resterai
à la mêlée française mais j'espère la
défendre longtemps parce qu'à
l'intérieur du français j'ai la
possibilité de prendre et reprendre le
rôle comme ça avec les mêmes partenaires
et on est vraiment une sacrée bande de
comédiens et on s'aime beaucoup donc on
a à coeur de défendre toujours ce
travail avec prince of wales et j'espère
à défendre longtemps à l'intérieur de la
comédie française
racine je pense que c'est évidemment ces
moteurs préféré pardon avec kick off
c'est je pense un très très grand pour
ne pas dire un des plus grands auteurs
dramatiques
justement parce qu'il a écrit déroule de
femmes qui sont tout à fait
exceptionnels qui sont de tous les âges
de toutes les conditions et qui
traversent des états absolument
incroyable et merveilleux et bien sûr je
ne peux pas ne pas évoquer le personnage
de phèdre que j'ai travaillé vrai est
construit avec patrice chéreau
c'est comme on dit c'est le le plus beau
des rôles parce que c'est un peu comme
hamlet pour les garçons envoyée je crois
que tout comédienne a envie un jour ou
l'autre de jouer la partition de fait
quel que soit son âge d'ailleurs
c'est un être profondément délicat et
extrêmement cultivé au courant de
beaucoup de choses et l'asvel sur la
pièce britannicus un avis extrêmement
précis de même qu'il avait un casting
qui était incroyablement précis et juste
c'est à dire de défendre la tragédie
aussi avec des gens très jeune je pense
que dans la maison à la comédie
française il ya dû avoir des
britanniques us
je sais pas j'ai peut-être et là que ce
soit britannicus que ce soit juni que ce
soit narcisse
ils ont une trentaine d'années est sur
scène ils ont l'air d'avoir entre 18
elle attend quoi
c'était important ça pour lui je crois
vraiment stéphane moitoiret comme eric
ruf construit toujours ses décors et je
pense que ça l'aide à avoir le recul
nécessaire pour travailler la pièce
c'était fin de prendre à quelqu'un aussi
qui est très présent physiquement c'est
à dire qu'à chaque reprise de cette
pièce il est là pour les répétitions
et puis il donne de nouvelles notes et
si vous voulez ça pour moi c'est
indispensable c'est à dire qu'il
abandonne jamais le spectacle ils
parlent pas aux quatre coins du monde
fascine part aux quatre coins du monde
mais en tout cas pour nous il revient
toujours et je pense que c'est très
important que les mises en scènes soient
cadrées qu'elle soit reprise pas
uniquement avec des assistants mère
aussi avec des metteurs en scène
parce que c'est ça aussi qui permet au
travail d'aller plus loin
j'ai été extrêmement touché que ces
crânes pense avoir voilà je connaissais
son travail on se connaissait assez peu
parce que je pense que c'est quelqu'un
d'assez timide et moi aussi
donc en fait par le passé il m'avait
proposé une fois déjà de travailler avec
lui j'étais pas disponible
mais voilà et cette proposition est
revenu c'était une double proposition
parce que c'était entrée à la comédie
française avec ce rôle là alors moi si
vous voulez je connaissais pas
l'historique de la maison pardon et je
le connaissais pas mais quelqu'un comme
françois florent en qualité mon
professeur d'art dramatique maggie
m'enfin voyons tu te rends pas compte
c'est l'idéal du entre français avec
ceux grands rôles du répertoire
c'est magnifique et 12 bon ça n'a fait
que me mettre une pression
supplémentaire mais bon c'est vrai que
c'était merveilleux c'était merveilleux
c'est marine
[Musique]